you're welcome to this video playing
grandma sadena meat from Russia so I
have a look I to a gaby alien ok around
to 600 you know ok Kings Indian then
let's let's check what happens in the
exchange with h three left good good
results with this opening so very solid
but still I tend to forget things I
think there should be seven less than
normal moose is discipline isn't this
not sure is a five is a bit early or
maybe I'm confusing things this is of
course possible
hmm not sure
yeah this looks okay for black he's got
Bishop d7 hmm bit of a shame okay so um
let's see knock do you wanna could also
castle long would bring the king nearer
to the Queen side
not sure I just I just thought that this
is not good at all he's got age 6 hey
doesn't definite re yeah I thought he
has got age six but I've called the
night is hanging at the moment this I
didn't didn't fear so much yeah he's
playing really quickly so should I yeah
I wonder if I should try to exchange
this quickly yeah I want to I want to
get rid of one roof here this is um
probably a good thing my king is a bit
open I think he plays them exchange this
one and now just came b12 to him to
exchange one pair of rooks came right
back and rooks you want to come yeah
yeah yeah he can he can do all that but
still I don't think this is too great
maybe looks you one note that are not
necessarily playing for a draw I mean
it's a caring imagine damn near the
Queen side so the King I mean I'm nearer
to the Queen side so should I try to get
the pond back on shouldn't I
yeah I guess I should play the smooth
first and now let's see what happens
let's try to approach the a porn king b3
a form so here in Bishop c5
hmm feel good about that
mmm that's a great of a shame I really
forgot about the smooth I'd take
pressure tank special be five takes
takes King deform I have the weight I
can still do that I forgot to parking it
for why this was bad wow I just I was
only thinking about King deform not King
f4 yeah I'm talk about giving away
giving away a game for nothing and yeah
this was bad night recently as I should
never ever lose this game of course
absolutely idiotic I'm always better in
this end game just just slightly better
maybe maybe it's it should be a drop
problem but I should never lose I forgot
about king of form y am very stupid
point since I can't just play that here
King king before no no way I'm ever
losing this position I mean the question
is if black and draw probably you cannot
yeah this is just it's just better for
white disposition so yeah yeah I forgot
first I forgot about this move which is
really bad and then I just miscounted I
can I can try to play on here but of
course it's already spoiled
check yeah I'm not sure maybe I'm maybe
even Bishop e7 here
yeah a bit i'm a bit stunned because you
played all this immediately instantly
everything's easy and i think this is
just a bad end game for black I'm sorry
even if I played it like an idiot it's
still a bad end game and he just played
this all instantly like what what are
you doing you idiot
don't know maybe King King King up first
maybe this is a lot of tempo as possible
i wanted to prevent night of five or
Bishop d8 is interesting maybe this is
better try to try to get the a porn and
the computer evaluation is really
interesting and completely nonsense King
is six Bishop b5 says that this position
is equal which is of course not true
I've got the beep on here and this is
just quite similar to being being one
porn why this is just better maybe black
and draw and white is just better yeah
g4 was already a step in the wrong
direction but still shouldn't lose of
course I can I complain I'd be three
he'd been this born probably yeah I
completely forgot about King fo i only
had only saw this and this um probably
not losses but King F was very easy yeah
given away a half a point here at least
alright thanks for watching